world war one was a war of losers even
the winners lost
amongst the countries which did lose
perhaps the greatest loser was the
kingdom of hungary
which lost 70 percent of its land and
about 65 percent of its population
and given that many in the hungarian
government were opposed to the war
at least at first why was hungary in
particular punished so severely
so at the outbreak of the war the
kingdom of hungary was made up of many
different peoples many of whom frankly
wanted out and as such for those in
charge maintaining hungary's integrity
was more important than any territorial
conquest
as opposed to the austrian half of the
empire that sought territory in italy
and in poland and was overwhelmingly
pro-war
there are many reasons why the antarette
pushed for the breakup of the kingdom of
hungary
the first was that this wasn't a
negotiation but a dictat
countries that lose wars as completely
as austria-hungary did weren't in a
position to negotiate over the terms
the second reason was that they had made
many promises of national sovereignty
during the war to groups like the czechs
and the polish
which was in return for these people
launching rebellions or simply refusing
to fight for the empires that they
currently lived in
the antante also assured countries like
romania and serbia that their
territorial claims on the habsburg
empire would be respected
and so that's why places like
transylvania were bargained away
irrespective of the hungarian
government's wishes
now this wasn't a case of the anton
presenting some united front
britain was fairly unconcerned about
what territory hungary would keep and
what its allies in the region would
receive
since its primary concern was the
ottoman empire in germany and what it
could get from them
the united states was a big supporter of
self-determination as a principle but
its leadership had no experience nor
much interest in dictating the borders
of countries in southeastern europe
the main architects of hungary's breakup
were italy mostly for its own
territorial ambitions and notably
france the french were entirely focused
on the decades that were to come after
the war
and france wished to build a strong
alliance with the countries in the
region aimed at the new soviet union and
any resurgent germany
and making sure that these potential
allies got what they wanted from hungary
was a big part of that plan
so that's all seth would right well no
the hungarians had hoped that the front
lines at the armistice would be where
hungary's new borders would be
yet as the treaty of trianon was being
negotiated by the anton the liberal
hungarian government collapsed and it
was replaced by a social democratic one
which had made an agreement with the
communist party
and when they were in power the
communists swiftly purged everyone else
and declared that hungary was a
communist state and one which wouldn't
accept any territorial losses
something it proved by swiftly invading
czechoslovakia and starting another war
with romania
for the anton this focused minds and
made it clear that the hungarians didn't
accept their defeat
and that they would likely seek to fight
again as soon as they were able to in
order to reclaim their old territory
this fact terrified the nations on
hungary's borders and so they demanded
via the french that the terms be harsh
the communist government collapsed in
late 1919 and after this the french took
a much more lenient approach to the
hungarians and sought to offer them this
so long as they agree to an anti-soviet
alliance the reason being that the
soviets were busy invading poland and
the french were terrified of what they
could do if they won
these plans went nowhere because the
polish managed to defeat the soviets on
their own
and the nations in southeastern europe
wouldn't countenance anything except
absolute humiliation for hungary
and so alongside broad restrictions on
the size of its military hungary lost
most of its population and its territory
and the country took on the shape that
it has today
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly moneymaker alex
schwinn mr wolf captain cydog adam's
daughter
skye chappelle marvin cassell aaron the
white mo
james castaneda jordan longley jerry
landon gustav swan rasheed ali winston k
wood boogery wiggely
spinning three plates copper tone maggie
paskowski spencer lightfoot
matthew shipley robert wetzel corso
wolff the mc whopper anthony beckett
marcus asner lil brepentisi and charles
the first